they face wade miley who has been
magnificent for the reds his numbers
western and southern
look for way to really once again try to
establish that fastball on the inner
half
and it is 11 games as the opposite base
hit over farmer
lead off single lukey betts
trust that your hitter is going to make
contact
and he didn't
pull
taps it back to milo
and miley works around the lead off hit
no score the reds will come to that they
oppose clayton kershaw his numbers from
western and southern clay kershaw you
see i think the thing this step stands
out for me is the 20 walks and the 132
strikeouts that's a good
ratio right there
to start his due to the strikeout
[Applause]
reds down in order against a future hold
a favor
corey seeger leads it off and he yanks
the first one in a line over the ship
first pitch and a base hit here in the
second
nice base hit
pick off they got them in a rundown
stevenson flicks to india
miley on the cover gets fed
and did we have interference called on
the base paths here it appears yes
that an arm bar was used to slow up
seeger
and david bell is out
and iasonia and john bacon the second
base umpire are not on the same page
and now they're calling them out
so david bell goes back to his bench now
dave roberts is out and the umpires
conference
well i think the idea is that corey
seeger
went out of the baseline to make contact
with jonathan india
a pitch for miley smith coming inside
and smith golf swing deep to left field
aquino to the track he's at the wall
there it goes
25th of the season and the dodgers draw
first spread
taylor goes the other way but his first
base hit of the weekend
three straight hits to open this second
on 2-2 locks drills the ball right
center field towards the gap and go on
two-run bullet for gavin lux
second home run of the frame and it's
three-nothing
one out one on and here is seeger seeger
turns on the first one that he sees and
launches it to la ranger
two-run home run corey seeger and the
dodgers lead 5-0
on three home runs it's one one to
taylor
is rifled to left that'll get into the
corner
hit parade continues for the dodgers
taylor is two for two
[Applause]
[Music]
goes after the first one that's past
india
six nothing dodgers lux has driven in
three over the first three innings
and seven over the last three games
the one-two
farmer for the ground ball to third
turner picks it up
goes across the diamond
farmer's retired first out of the four
nick castellano stepping and he fly to
right in his first outback
nick castellanos
off the base of the wall
head first plunge in the second
castillanos comes home
reds have their first run at six to one
swinging in a miss on a motivated fast
sprawl they're in the inning reds get
their first run of the game but kershaw
gets his sixth k through four innings
the two two
like that one swinging a miss
strikeout number seven for kershaw first
out of the fifth
joe kelly to get out of this inning and
tony gunslin possibly to start the next
inning
that breaks in and a good finish to the
day for clayton kershaw
eight k's in just one run over five
here's the pitch to friedel first pitch
t.j friedl
to right field home run
his second
major league
so amazing to watch these young players
come up through the organization and
make instant
impact on this team at this level
right back at it
single to center
he's saying man the big leagues this is
easy
pass justin turner
cradle through second
lux now gathers in the left wave on for
freedle india shuts it down in second
friedel scores rbi double three
run game
india goes
pitch away throw to third not there huge
steal of third base with one out
see jonathan india at second base
thinking about this for a while
over the leafing pull holes to plate
jonathan india and the reds within two
extended to seven the debate on the
first pitch that he sees in the night
3-0 pitch
grounded is short knocked down by farmer
who's only players at first and he mails
it over there
that's heads home and they get some
insurance
dodgers catching a break
as the reds fail to catch the ball
[Applause]
[Music]
whether you don't know if it's bone or
pad
[Music]
what's on the pad you know
thank goodness he wears that
but below the pad could be pain
oh yeah that's one of the pads
there here we go payoff pitch
seeger
takes ball four and the dodgers lead it
eight to four
taking a couple of those runs right back
[Applause]
to right field betts looks up
volo off the bench cranks a homer
31st home run of the year is 89th run
batted in
2-2 from janssen to barnhart
that does it
the dodgers take the series from the
reds they've won eight of their last
nine
and they cut off a half game with the
giants just underway in san francisco
they're within a game and a half with 12
of them left